pandemia en la sombra la violencia
machista se ha agudizado en
latinoamérica desde la llegada del cob y
19 según la onu 30 de las mujeres del
continente han sufrido de violencia
física o sexual por parte de sus parejas
y 11% a manos de otras personas ha
aumentado muchísimo las llamadas
denuncias han aumentado las agresiones
y digamos a través de whatsapp a través
de
instagram de facebook de todos los
medios sociales de comunicación la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe reportó que en el 2020 hubo al
menos cuatro mil diecinueve feminicidios
en américa latina' una cifra que a pesar
de que muestra una disminución del 10 6
por ciento de los casos con respecto a
2019 es dispar entre los países de la
región las tasas más altas de la región
las tienen honduras república dominicana
y el salvador y en bolivia durante los
71 días que duró la cuarentena se
registraron dos mil 935 denuncias de
violencia sexual y 113 feminicidios
durante los confinamientos estrictos y
mixtos yo diría que la violencia contra
las mujeres en américa latina y en
bolivia tiene dimensiones endémicas el
informe muestra que los feminicidios se
dan en mayor cantidad en las mujeres de
entre 30 y 44 años pero de la situación
de las niñas menores de 15 años al menos
40 fueron víctimas del delito
[Aplausos]